did you have to audition for Lord of the
Rings or did someone see you I audition
many times I auditioned originally for
the role of faramir
and then I got to call back the Hubbards
in London who I had met Roz Hubbard
who's like a big casting agent in London
it was one of my first meetings when I
was 16 I moved to London when I was 16
and she was like I think you could do
anything and I was like yeah it was like
it was like a vote of confidence that
was so inspiring anyway she had brought
me in for this and they brought me back
for Legolas and so I I had been on tape
for for the one role and then I and then
I taped again for Legolas how many years
were you shooting Lord of the Rings for
the was it was it two years oh yeah I
mean yeah 18 months and then and then
going back for reshoots for a few months
here and there five months but it was a
yeah and the guys you're working with
are not lightweights I mean these are
that was amazing I mean like Christopher
Lee Ian McKellen in home and so what is
it like are you this overconfident guy
who walks into a situation like Lord of
the Rings first acting job you're with
those you know and it's like this
[__] legendary guy no I'm not that
overconfident guy I'm like I'm I'm very
studious so like I'm like like so for
example IOD auditioned for Moulin Rouge
about six times for Bas lemon and I
thought that was going to be the one
that went my way just before Lord of the
Rings and it was around the same sort of
time but you didn't get it no I didn't
they went with Leo McGregor so they were
going to do unknowns we obviously I
would have been there and then I was at
drama school and they they went with
like Ewan and Nicole so it was a very
different way to go but um and I you
know I loved that movie but obviously
actually Lord of the Rings in terms of
in terms of what that movie and that
character did what it does for your
career your career was exactly different
and I didn't I didn't know I didn't
think about it but I was so I would I
would I would learn all my sides all my
learn everything studious study so that
was off book and like really focused and
could do what I needed to do so I'm not
the guy who walks into the room and
thinks he's the most confident and but
you're very prepared but I try to be
very prepared and if I'm not prepared
I'm like then I'm like nervous if you're
doing a movie like that for those two
years are you living like in the sense
that hey this is this is a deal breaker
if I screw this up I want to do my very
best you don't go out at night I mean
are you just like kind of living for
your craft I mean listen in New Zealand
it was awesome and there were dinners
and yeah of course we'd have drinks on
the weekends every now and again but it
was but you it was so it was such a
magical time you know like it was it was
you bonded with those actors yeah that's
when you guys all went out and got
tattoos yeah the Lord of the Rings
that's right too yeah yeah right on Lord
of the Rings you probably didn't even
get to participate in the big because
they signed you when you were nobody I
got nothing 175 Grand wow
175. well yeah I mean how many billions
yeah for the three oh did they see you
coming yeah no listen the greatest gift
of my life of course
yeah and it's like can you do it again
you do it again for half the money
thank you